this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
very exciting start to this drive don't
even worry about coming to my face my
name is Patrick and on camera is Manu
we have vines very very close to a
Buffalo right now we are just seconds
away from a hunt we are coming to you
live from the Masai Mara here in Kenya
any questions or comments please use
that ashtag safari Wat but these lions
are literally 10 meters 30 feet away
from the Buffalo and the Buffalo you
have not noticed yet this is
edge-of-your-seat stuff this is - ivory
the other day we had the old way no
prides with through buffalo but they
were one down now there is butternut
thrown into the mix one of the older
ones more experienced sorry this is
anyone's game today very close now this
is intense stuff very exciting start to
this drive almost as if it was on the
queue oh wow
okay so we the butler in the line is oh
so close now sitting there looking at it
from literally five meters 15 feet this
is unreal I'm ecstatic right now I
wonder which one they're going to make a
move on okay so the buffalos know the
snare alright and now we're on we're on
got one at the back there we'll try and
get the anchor up I'm gonna move up now
I'm gonna move up
Chase is on this is hectic stuff this
might get a little bit bumpy okay making
the attempt at the anchor again
okay so one is on the back one's got the
back position now okay keep it off again
kicked off again so I am trying to get
this point so this as possible they are
moving very quickly right now crazy okay
so hey so okay so we've got another
attempt at the back
please okay so hold on guys
thank you through this bit okay so the
action has slowed down a bit which is
good gives us a chance to catch up
line up still on these Buffalo I haven't
made an escape yet
all right
so here we are here we are we've caught
up the Buffalo just trying to keep this
one at bay we can see the other one on
the side we'll be helping out here so it
is to Buffalo versus five line right now
so the male's coming into the back but
still sitting too far away to make a
move all right so both the Buffalo are
involved in this Nair
the Lions just sitting and patiently I
can see four lion heads all pretty much
surrounding the Buffalo here so one of
the Lions will try and get the anchor
down in the back and then the next point
will probably be the Achilles tendons
that they will want to get try to sever
and stop them from being able to step
forward okay so I can see all five lines
now and they are closing in on this one
I am a bit lost for words right now this
is intense he's going to make the move
just not being able to get into the
position right now as I did say there is
only through all the females in this
pride but this these two females have
made successful buffalo kill on their
own when the two younger females of this
pride and the younger male was still not
old enough to be able to participate in
hunt so they have the experience they
have the numbers it's just a matter of
whether they can piece it all together
okay I'm just going to move a little bit
further forward now
[Music]
so if anyone did join at me yesterday
you would have seen a very similar
situation unfolding almost as if deja vu
are great there's a road here
that's even better so we have been
following the old way nose for about two
or three hours now since they have been
reunited with butternut and they did try
and hunt a warthog that failed but these
Buffalo came right after now it's just
gonna be a matter of wearing it the
Buffalo down and getting in a good spot
this could play out for a while
definitely as a better chair they have a
better chance than they did yesterday
oh I didn't even if the Buffalo the
courtesy to finish its meal we can see
it's about grass hanging out of its me
out there still keep moving forward
okay actually a month try and come
around and get
absolutely insane stuff here in the
Maasai Mara in Kenya we are watching
along please who use the hashtag Safari
live or these YouTube chat stream to
communicate with us tell us what you
think is going to happen here it is
anyone's game at the moment
Buffalo keeping the Lions a favor they
are being worn down and the lines
definitely not giving up the hunt
being pushed into higher ground now
Buffalo has a nice position on the top
they're looking down oh that could have
been a silly move separating it from the
other Buffalo and allowing the Lions to
get in a better spot this the male seems
just a bit timid in hunts it does have a
lot of scars from a past injury and that
may contribute to it being a little bit
timid Buffalo showing it that it does
not want a bar of them keeping them away
right now I can only see three of the
Lions the male has just jumped out the
back it's always keeping its distance I
have the other two gone
Wow
things are settling but this is
definitely not over I'm just wondering
why these other two I if they've come
around the back and they could be in a
good position but I'm not seeing any
heads in the grass at the moment so just
yeah stay quiet for a little bit let you
listen to this nor to this Buffalo the
grunts are you cold
very exciting stuff so the two bubbler
through Buffalo back together now it's
likely gonna be on the run again ah do
we knows going to keep up the chase yes
they are
okay so I can see the other three now
okay so they're not out of it
sorry still not over so you have three
on the left of the Buffalo and two on
the right
see these three here
Wow this is deja very isn't if the oh we
nose versus through Buffalo's two days
in a row been very lucky it's been very
interesting to follow along with this
pride now but another did show up
without Cubs today but they were in
hunting mode they were on the move when
after they were reunited so there is
potential that she could have stashed
the Cubs away or the cub I only saw her
with one yesterday after four days ago
there was three so well we can finally
really hope that they are again that she
has stashed at least one of them are
waiting for this hunt Wow looks like it
is settling down a bit I still don't
think it's over
Buffalo doing a very good job last
couple days mmm okay so now we've got
one of the lionesses walking away
mmm I wonder if they're trying to get a
better position and whether they have
given up you say that's three failed
hunts in a row I've seen three Buffalo
and one warthog said they were hunting
warthog earlier but they didn't make it
great attempt at it
- is moving up where we saw those
Buffalo when they got that high ground
Mina Murray wants to know how do the
Lions kill a large Buffalo well there is
something it called the kiss of death
that is very effective if they can get
their mouths over the snouts in the
mouths of the Buffalo they can actually
stop their breathing and suffocate them
it that way you'll see also a lot of
biting a lot of tearing going for those
vital organs so once they have the
Buffalo on the ground that's when they
can really start to punch in and make
that kill so the male lion moving off in
the other direction - it looks like they
may have given up so we can see that
scar there just on its hip from their
former injury and that's why I say I
think it's a bit timid
okay yeah so we will wrap up this
unscheduled at broadcast but we are
going to stay with the oh we no pride to
see if they do decide to make another
hunt they are looking at very hungry and
anything could happen
so if you do want to follow along with
all the action sign it in on YouTube and
go to safari alive and you can watch a
long interact with this using the
hashtag Safari live on Twitter I hope to
see you all in a few moments
Wow it is all happening this morning we
are going to send you back down to South
Africa where the action is continuing
with some wild dogs yes it is all
happening this morning we've got
wonderful wild dogs how exciting is that
and of course it's not the morning it is
the afternoon the Sun sits Safari so
glad to have you guys on board with me
I am T'Challa and a sip on camera with
me yes coming here from Juma in South
Africa now you are up there with Pat in
the Maasai Mara lots of things happening
this morning this afternoon I keep
thinking it's the morning but we have
wonderful wild dogs now these are the
same ones that we had or say part of the
same pack that we had this morning in
this area and this is the Ambani
invested by Kawai pack as far as we know
now we can only see a few individuals I
haven't seen them all
and what you are looking at right now is
bad there are about three three guys
just lying down in the grass there of
course it is hot it's a blistering 33
degrees Celsius here and so that's we go
I think it's about 91 degrees Fahrenheit
so it's really hot the dogs think so too
and they've perched themselves on this
nice patch of grass yeah it's really
hard to see almost but you can see that
sort of artistic coat through the cross
which I love gorgeous remember this is a
totally interactive Safari oh I know
you've lifted up your head see this guy
would like to you - please interact with
us and use the hashtag Safari live on
Twitter of course the YouTube chat
stream always wonderful to hear from you
guys
I'm hoping one a and these guys actually
get a kill and they can eat nicely and
maybe we'd be able to see it as well
very very cool yeah everyone's happy to
see the wild dogs again I am absolutely
happy to see the wild dogs since I've
been back from leave I haven't seen them
hello people are starting to get up a
bit look at those huge ears listening
around like I said it's really really
hot and we have they have they have
positioned themselves in a really nice
place where then they've got a bit of
water across the road their child of the
universe you'd like to know if they have
hunted today well rusty has them earlier
this morning and they were not
successful from what I understand so I
really hope that today maybe once the
Sun Goes Down a little bit it gets a
little bit cooler because that's what
they need that's what all these
predators need they need it to be
slightly cooler because in the day it's
just way too hot to be able to expend
your your energy that way you just these
animals would just overheat so they're
waiting so that gets cooler and then
hopefully we'll be able to see them in
action that would be something
they have moved a little bit they went
completely flat in the grass when we got
you there were under a nice Quarry Bush
in the shade and they moved a little bit
too they've got a little bit startled by
something there was a loud sort of
elephants cream you've ever heard that
if we catch it again we will definitely
point it out to you but it does do that
laughing it does it's like it's such a
disparate disparate scream and that kind
of picked their heads up and they ran
around a little bit and then they moved
to another shady spot so I really
thought they were gonna go in the hunt
no they were just a bit startled and
then they popped right back down
baby Jess you want to know if wild dogs
bark like domestic dogs know the song
that they make is a really really
strange noise I mean obviously they
whine like a dog doesn't you hear that
kind of thing and then you hear that the
the noise that they usually make which
is so sort of quintessential wild dog so
the science sounds like a siren going
off so that's how they communicate
remember animals don't only communicate
with sound they also communicate with
smell and with touch tactile
communication so there's all that going
on as well
they were know exactly who's part of
their group they're members they know
where they are
very very big complex mammals are
because now you see them kind of turning
and a vehicle in the US and that just
shows you how sensitive their ears can
be a vehicle near in the air stand on
their engine and there's been like
satellite dishes huge satellite dishes
that kind of move around to listen you
see it with the caduceus as well very
cool so I will sit with them for a
little longer they are of course other
people that want to join our sighting so
we'll see how much longer we can stay
here in the meantime I'd likely send you
over to d3 a lovely lovely lady and she
is a freelance guide for us so let me
introduce you to her
afternoon everyone my name is Deirdre
and you've joined me here in Juma and
Game Reserve also still in the Kruger
National Park and we're on the hunt with
cameraman Craig and Jamie and we're on
the hunt for tangela the great Duke of
the north we were fortunate enough to
see him this morning at the Guara Penn
which is just around the corner so keep
your eyes aren't look for the spots he
was quite full so he was quite lazy this
morning so we're gonna see if we can
catch up with him
[Music]
as most of you know and your regular
viewers will definitely recognize it's a
new face on Safari life I have to admit
that we both share a friend a longtime
friend Stephan Venter booed
he's been nagging and nagging for me to
come and join an interview drive for
Safari live for years I have been
resisting but I have to tell you Steph
Paul you've won here I am so this
morning we gotcha Jamie suggested let's
quickly check
Gouri pen for a leopard we drove here
and as we stopped we almost got after to
look for tracks and single I was lying
right down here on the left hand side of
the vehicle in the grass fast asleep he
didn't even bother you didn't even lift
his head he just lay there sleeping and
then what he did after that was he got
up and he moved a little bit further
down the road and he found another shady
spot so we're just gonna carry on a
little bit further and see if we able to
relocate it
now obviously most of you have started
to see that the bushes are still pretty
thick at this time of year and because
he's got such good camouflage we're
gonna just drive nice and slowly so we
don't drive right past him
and thanks everybody for the welcomes
he's right yeah he's on that lift and
oopsy
I did give him a bit of a surprise so
we're just gonna let him settle he's
right next to us I'm gonna just reverse
let me know when you've got him oh he's
just hiding just behind this bush will
oh no he's gonna go back I can't even
see his spots he's trying to hide in the
shade I'm just gonna give him a second
he's just gonna come out you might be
able to see him No here he comes
that perfect camouflage that I was
talking about well here we go I'm just
gonna reposition the vehicle so that
you're able to get a bit of you this is
pretty much how we lift him this morning
sleeping he appeared to have eaten
something last night because you can see
he's got a nice fat belly and was this
heat he's also panting quite heavily
which of the viewers think tingle as
their favorite lipid so a little bit of
a background about myself is a question
from some of the new some of the regular
viewers I've been guiding for about
twenty years started my career in the
Kruger National Park as a very young 18
year old safari guard and then moved on
to the eastern cape I did sort of three
and a half years they all within South
Africa then moved on to the Waterberg
and then to the Kruger for about eight
years and then for the last two half
years pretty much spent time traveling
on Overland Safari so fortunately enough
to have travelled right up through
Africa from South Africa Cape Town all
the way up to Nairobi and Uganda he's
just sleeping so nicely they're very
unlikely for him to think about doing
anything active this afternoon now with
an ass-full Bailey like that he's likely
to just spend the afternoon sleeping
he's quite close to their pen as you saw
so if he wants to drink some more water
that's as far as he's probably going to
move
always marveled at the size of the feet
Wow here you got some action with
Trishula with the wild dogs so enjoy
that Tiana's beat I in fact huge aren't
they he was such a pleasure to see this
morning you can see is a nice big julep
who's always nice to see him I'm so glad
that Deirdre found him so she can have
something really nice for her first
drive which is cool anyway I have as you
can see left the wild dogs there were
other people that wanted to come in and
watch as well and then we said let's
come back later when they might be doing
something so we decided let's go check
out calico pen it's a nice hot day like
I said gotta go pants a good place to
maybe have a look and then I will make
my way further down sort of to the south
of the reserve oh I think that's a good
plan see if what's happening at the
hyena den always good value
entertainment I find a hyena din so I'm
excited hope you guys are excited of
course you can also let me know what you
want to see or what you would know what
you would like to see of course nothing
too crazy
that was our stop you'd like me to find
you a Pangolin of course you can let me
know and there it could yeah you can let
me know but I don't I don't I'll be able
to help you just yet
so here we are this road here is
Galago and then I go shortcut and this
will take us to Penn that's why I want
to see if anything's having a drink it's
always nice to go to those sort of areas
especially when it's soft like this but
we have had a bit of rain so there are a
few little kind of puddles here and
there and what that does it's dispersed
is the water kind of around the reserve
and when you have that you can't really
rely on the big pads because really an
animal can access what in any little dip
it finds but it has been a bit drier
lately
no did a dude rain a few nights ago so
let's try our luck
now I have a request for yes I knew it
was a request a request for horn balls
strangely this morning when we were
driving back from we were just kind of
went out on the little drive with Jamie
daydrian myself and we on our way back
not even half a K from camp there were
two ground horn balls right outside
there and they're always a pleasure to
look at always even to hear them it's so
cool and can you see how thick the
bushes got me it's what you think I mean
you can even with the ground hornbills
you could sort of just see them because
there on the grass was the height that
they were but they have that obvious
black plumage and the red of course
underneath so it was easy to see ah we
have the murderer
the aerial murderer that's her ugly
we have camera killers and aerial
murderers on this property okay let's
see it almost there guys almost there
what do you think is gonna be there I'm
gonna say I think I think there will be
let's be honest I don't think there'll
be anything but if there is something
it'll be an antelope
I would think let's see Wow it is so
thick that you can you can hardly even
see the pen cast what do you think will
be there a dove cuz thinks a dove will
be there you know you cut you probably
very right Kersey Hey look at how tall
that grasses you can barely see that pen
well always worth the look sometimes you
just have a feeling and you just got to
go with it and if you don't find if you
don't try as is with everything in life
you will never know will you stays the
pen fuss cool let us head back out
[Music]
mm-hmm well while I look for something
special
Deidre has got something very special
for you but of course you know what that
is
hi we're still with sangala he's still
there sleeping and I keep calling him
Tenggara and I'll tell you why I worked
for a very long time on a reserve way we
actually had a small little female
leopard and her name was tingly so it's
eight years of em graining of a leopard
name and she actually got her name
because the first time she became
independent and left her mother she
stumbled upon some lion cubs and she
actually killed him which we were
surprised that a leopard would kill the
lion cub and that's how she got the name
Pingala which means little lion
so no disrespect to ding Ghana which
means shy which clearly is not he's
definitely grown into a different
leopard from being shy so comparative to
other lipids I've seen in my career he's
actually pretty good looking for his age
believe he's around about 11 maybe
almost 12 so he's got a lot of
experience under his belt and asked big
territorial mail and I'm sure most of
the viewers that have been watching him
for a long time and have seen a lot of
his accomplishments he's mating with the
females these territorial markings his
hunting skills I saw the clip from
Tristan the other day where he went
right into the water burrow hoping to
find a water but he was not so lucky so
as they get a little bit older hunting
sometimes becomes a little bit harder
obviously they're getting pressure from
potentially other territorial males
wanting to move in maybe they're they
younger but stronger so there may be a
challenger on the horizon for him
so he may also start to start stealing
some of the ladies kills even I believe
he steals from his own son sometimes so
I don't know if you necessarily stole
the kill 38 because we haven't seen any
evidence of any other leopards around
but he certainly got quite a full belly
many of the viewers got any questions
about lipids
we're in the best spot to ask me that
question Lauren my favorite animal is in
fact a lipid and probably because the
first half of my career I worked in
places where lipid were very very scarce
and very shy so didn't get to see them
often and then towards the latter half
of the career spend time in a new
reserve that didn't really have relaxed
livers at all so we've got to go from
completely wild lipids to over years
working with them that they eventually
became very similar to ting gonna relax
with the vehicles and if you'd like this
but just the sheer beauty those spots
just everything's just perfect so you
use the spots on the top lip to tell
them apart literally just the top row of
spots and will help you identify
different lipids from different areas
you can also use the tackiness of the
ears sometimes that's a distinct give
away but with Mal lipids sometimes that
becomes quite hard especially if they've
been fighting and they get some new
Nicks and notches and ears then you may
confuse them but fortunately when
they're the size of Tenggara and they
own a very large territory you're
generally finding the same male in the
same places and areas
Wow so now you're racking my brain here
I've got to go back quite far and just
been asked sir I didn't get the name but
my favorite leopard sighting would
probably have to be when a female
introduced to tiny little fluffy Cubs to
us and we were right next to them and
she brought them out and the two Cubs
started playing it was just in a river
line in a nice little drainage area and
those two Cubs became also the stars of
that particular property year over time
okay
now they're just flooding my head I just
keep remembering all sorts of sightings
that I remember you'd see them one of
them was stalking a scrub here and
unfortunately the scrub here wasn't so
lucky and wasn't so alert and got
grabbed while also a young female
leopard and by the time she got hold of
it and and unfortunately dispatched it
she had to obviously pluck all the fur
out and it didn't really look like she
actually enjoyed that meal for a while
because all she was doing was spitting
the scrub here for out of her mouth
before she actually got a bite to eat
you can see the Flies are bothering him
a little bit every now and again he's
nose twitches and he gets his poor ready
to swat them away moving look at the
size of those feet you can see very very
nicely the claws sticking out and for
them they sort of there are retractable
claws but the levers will obviously
bring them up when they've stopped the
prey and they jump on the prey to grab
it's they'll use their claws to hold
onto the prey and particularly with hard
prayed things like warthog and then it
helps them hold on so until they get the
throat group but also with them helps
them climbing trees so some of the trees
here have very loose bark and it allows
them some nice grip especially for a
male leopard or a female carrying a nice
heavy year meal up the tree to hide it
from the hyenas
so question for the viewers in one tweet
which is your favorite leopard of the
Safari live shows
it's just snoozing this is what you
would call a Sunday afternoon snooze
everybody the only thing is not doing a
snoring
giraffe girl is asking why did I decide
to become a guide well I grew up on a
farm so I'd always had the opportunity
to be outdoors with animals granted they
were farm animals we had donkeys and
ducks and geese and chickens even had a
pit chick and that was one of my first
pits and then I when I was in high
school I decided to do some volunteer
work in the zoo which was also working
with farmyard animals which I was
familiar with and just the love of
animals my entire life so then working
with those animals I left that and I
studied conservation and I've been in
the bush ever since but this is like a
dream career I've just spent the last
six months behind the desk being a desk
jockey and I definitely would rather be
sitting on a Land Rover
kingfisher nice woodland Kingfisher just
landed on the branches just above
Pingala did so it seems like the
unanimous decision is husana is the
favorite lipid of the show I have to
admit I'm yet to see him but I'm clearly
looking forward to it when he comes back
so that's a woodland Kingfisher it's
probably a little bit difficult with the
light but they have the most awesome
call that chewy that you hear around
about November in the bush they've just
migrated all the way from northern
Africa come down here and spend the
summer season yes so they starting to
think about moving back north and what's
interesting about them is that they
actually land up going over an entire
population of woodland kingfishers that
hang around at the equator so the
woodland kingfishers in the Mora these
ones overlap in the natal feos probably
also just coming in to have a good look
at ting Ghana he doesn't obviously feel
threatened by a leopard because he can
fly off but you do sometimes get other
birds that will alarm at leopards
particularly some of the Franklin's like
the crista Franklin and the spoof Isles
as well as even the gray go away bird
they often have something to say if
there's a leopard actively moving around
in an area they just try to give
everybody else a warning to say hey
there is a predator in the area and as
as a guide that's almost like sound that
you you can't ignore you have to go and
have a look and see what the birds are
telling you
if you're seeing his whiskers there he's
got such nice long whiskers and four
cats that's a very very important thing
for them their whiskers help them from a
sensory point of view okay after having
a look at his whiskers we're gonna send
you across to Tristana to see what she's
up to
whiskers what beautiful whiskers he must
have indeed but I have something pretty
to you know these African who poos they
like to follow me around I've seen so
many since I've been back all about even
now they're about four on the road and
this beautiful one perched on that
branch I think it looks so nice lovely
long beacon at Christy
really really cool one of the
understated birds I think because we see
them so often that you kind of get
spoiled and then you forget how
incredibly beautiful these birds are and
then you have God looks in a closer
detail and you can see the coloration on
the and the wing it's just it's a
stunning bird there you are moving to
the wind swing your branch isn't it
wind through the whoo beautiful well I
am on the road heading to the din and
Shane says this is your favorite but I'm
glad to hear it Shane it is definitely
one of my favorites like I've said to
you guys before it's very hard for me to
choose favorites it's one of the things
I least like to do is choose a favorite
because everything is my favorite I know
that's a bad thing
but it's true I love everything I just
can't stop anyway I am on the road to
the hyena den or almost on the road to
the hanging it in so we will end up very
soon so let us drive on also guys please
remember that the wild wild earth
expedition second one will be open for
bookings today after the sunset safari
and of course you can find out any extra
information you'd like and to actually
book and after the Sun sets safari has
finished and you can go onto our website
which is Wilder TV and it folds slash
expeditions and then you can read all
about and get an idea and of course come
and join us we had an excellent time
last the last time that everyone was
here it was also really nice to meet you
all and kind of get an idea of who are
these people that watch us and kind of
you know we have a relationship now so
it's always nice to meet you guys so
please please book we want it fully
booked so we can meet as many as you as
possible really nice sit down have a
nice dinner get to chat really cool so
please do that once the Safari closes
and go on to our website
oh I'm so glad it's starting to cool
down a bit whoo it was hot earlier it
was really hot
still so amazed at how big everything
has gotten when I was off-roading
through I can't remember when it was one
of these days recently and the grass
actually came to to my knee where this
door is open just on my right the grass
was touching me even though I'm in the
car it was that high
I must say I do enjoy just sort of
leisurely cruising through the bush you
see all the wonderful things I mean even
the dead branches look beautiful even
the dead branches
so many trees
now we also had tracks of a female
leopard apparently was spotted this
morning around this area as well so also
keeping an eye out for that but nothing
so far
now also had wonderful elephants around
this area you can see this or
contribution there's a few kind of
little pens along the road here so I'll
often see elephants kind of clean it's
slip in it which is really nice
hey you can have a look at the bush as
we drive past look it's like you're
right here how cool is that slow it down
for you you can actually see you nicely
can pass all all the big trees beautiful
stunning love what I do I mean I'm
almost at the din when I come back we
will be there hopefully it'll be busy in
the meantime let me send you over to TIA
tree with that beautiful spotted cat
so 10 Ghana still a flat cat and
speaking about flat cats I believe I've
got to get in my little pits as well so
I don't have any cats but we have five
dogs at home most people that come from
Johannesburg have the odd one or two
dogs and generally small dogs but I'm
going to show you the first one here
which is a very greedy lab black lab her
name is Bella and as you can see she's
pretty much wishing that that popcorn
will jump out of the popcorn pot and
then oh wait we've got more we have
another four so they all live happily
together in the household for three
Belgian Malinois one special one in the
middle that kind of thinks he's a wolf
so that session and Titan and Zeus and
Duke and believe me when the postman
goes past we definitely know about it
and no doubt maybe they're here meals
before alive and you'll get an
interesting clip on the Safari hashtag
Safari live pets
so speaking of cats I've been here for
two days and had the very fortunate
opportunity to spend some time out with
Jamie when we were with Columba
unfortunately she was in the rain
so she just finished her darker kill
that Tristan had seen in the morning and
she was out of the out of the tree and
she was on the ground and then it
started to rain and if there is one
thing that a cat hates is getting wet if
we look on the western horizon there
seems to be some storm clouds brewing
but the good news is the wind is blowing
them away from us so I'm hoping that
we're not going to get wet
tonight on Safari because today we
didn't put a roof on what the lumber
didn't decided to do was hide in the
bushes
James is asking a question am i Akeem
Berta do I like birds very very much
James I wouldn't call myself a twitcher
that I'll run around and spend time
going to specific areas to find a
specific bird but certainly if I am in a
new area then I will try and find as
many of the new birds as possible
probably the one that's on my wanted
list has to be a shovel and going to
Uganda just weren't in the right places
at the right times to have actually seen
a shoe ball but plenty of favorites but
shoe ball definitely top of the list
so that's the interesting a lot of the
birds at this time of the year because
we're heading into winter now a lot of
our migrants like that woodland
Kingfisher that we were looking at
earlier are on their way to move I
didn't catch the name in there but the
question is how large a meal can the
scat eat well a very good question
because what you will find with very
young lepers when they're inexperienced
when they're inexperienced they'll often
start with small things so they'll try
and catch squirrels Birds anything that
can stalk anything small and even like
to lumber which is that young female she
starts with small things so she started
with the daycare and as she improves her
hunting skills she'll probably be better
at catching Impala and that would
probably be about the biggest for a
female leopard but one lacked in Ghana
you'll find large large water back even
sometimes some adult kudu they they'll
just eat a variety for them it's also
what they're able to stalk up and catch
but in this area probably the majority
would swing towards feeding on Impala
I'd love to know what he ate because
average leopard male leopard probably
weighing anywhere over 80 kilos Dingaan
I might even be a bit more than that and
he's certainly a few kilos heavier after
his last meal so this heavy heavy
panting is twofold it's because he's
because he's got a full belly and he's
in the heat but good news is that the
Mara Pat is ready to show you a thing or
two in the Maura wow what an exciting
start to that driver I almost feel as if
I need to redo my introduction as I was
so caught up in the action that I just
kind of everything went blue my name is
Patrick joining me on camera is Manu and
we are coming to you live from the Masai
Mara here in Kenya if you have any
questions or comments please use the
hashtag it's safari live let you all let
me know if you're feeling as o as I am
after that to Buffalo hunts in two days
unfortunately both unsuccessful for the
Lions but fortunately for the Buffalo
and I'm sure many of you who like to see
at the prey get away it was a good thing
so yeah it kind of leads that
bittersweet taste in your mouth where
yeah one loses one wins but the winners
are looking at very hungry and poor
butternut is not looking well I'm not
sure exactly what it is but there is
something all over her neck I thought it
was big flies until they weren't moving
then I thought it might have been
massive ticks but then we had a closer
look and it appears to be some big black
welts all over her neck so I'm exactly
sure what it is but it doesn't look
pleasant for the poor
or girl and even further bad news I did
catch up with her yesterday and she only
had one cub with her she was desperately
desperately trying to find the other
ones we followed her from tree to tree
she went back to that original den site
where we first saw the three and just
couldn't find it then so yeah for poor
butternut and today as well we didn't
see her with a cub but then again they
did go out hunting so we call that with
him just went butternut actually
reunited with the rest of the oh we know
pride but then after that there was no
Cubs so perhaps she has stashed them of
or the hunt we can only really hope so
because otherwise that would mean it's
gone from three Cubs to no hugs
Oh anyway what an exciting at start to
this drive and Charlotte found wild dogs
auntie auntie new guide
everyone is concerned why I'm not
wearing green well actually I am I am it
is Saint me day I did so in all of the
excitement I forgot about that but I
don't actually have anything like proper
proper green to bring it out with me so
I do just have my khaki green jumper and
it is starting to get a little bit
chilly so I will pop it on for st.
Patrick's Day yes as I say fountain
governor as well so very cracking it
start to the drive maybe if someone has
a photo editor they can edit this a
little bit of a lighter more st. Patrick
II shade of green this is the only a
green attire that I had well I did have
also a green floral hat as well but it's
just probably not appropriate to wear on
Drive so unfortunately this is all I
have but happy st. Patrick's Day to
everyone around the world I hope you are
enjoying it I've of course of Irish
heritage and so we'll probably have a
little celebration later on so it seems
like Trish Allah is trying to continue
like it this morning and checking out I
mean this afternoon it's checking out
the fire
I definitely am trying to continue my
life and I think my luck will even
continue into the evening when we have a
celebration for st. Patrick's Day as
well well nothing like after the drive
to sit back and relax just a little bit
we really wanted to have a fire as well
but just a bit warm hopefully it'll get
a bit chilly and we can have a nice fire
so I am lucky yes I'm very lucky I've
had the the wild dogs and now I have
these beautiful guys you know how much I
love them absolutely love them so we
have cocci that's at the entrance there
slumped over what she does miss you know
when she's not being a beast she's the
cutest thing on earth and of course we
have the two other cuties you know I
think these both are pretties because we
know that plonk has the the much really
dark spots and the he has a two patches
of white just on each side of his of his
spine and he also has that kind of a C
upon his on his thigh and then I also
think on the other side he has kind of a
triangle without corners if that makes
sense and so these two I'm pretty sure
pretties too and we had a ribbon on the
other side of the termite of the the den
oh we're dozing off we can barely keep
our eyes open where's your friend plonk
see the flinch of the ear it's as if oh
just like a little baby I'm sleepy but
I'm not gonna sleep I'm not
well what was that what did I miss
something no speed puppet
Oh
now I was asked if hyenas have
territories that play hell I couldn't
quite hear what that was and and they do
they have they each clan has their own
territory and the area that they will
defend Oh
Playhouse Playhouse very nice like a
theater and yes they do they have
territories that they will defend in
areas that they will defend especially
areas where there have dens like this so
for example we are discussing it this
morning with Jaime H the end we are
talking about whether are the hyenas
because all the only hyenas that we've
seen or that we mostly see our Juma clan
and the juma clan there aren't a huge
amount of members but for what they
apparent territory kind of encompasses
it seems like it's a lot for a small
amount of hyena but then Jaime also told
us that when there was an elephant
carcass then there are other hyenas that
have come in as well
obviously they were fighting and other
sorts of things but it's interesting in
fact I was just thinking about it today
about the territories and and exactly
who else would come in and how would
they come in but so far I have just just
been lucky enough to be with our little
Chu my plan here everyone's sleepy
look at those
there you can clearly see it so when you
see a hyena track that's exactly what
you're seeing and I always love to see
the actual pole because it gives you a
good understanding of the shape and size
of that track so you can see that the
back pad only has two lobes whereas with
a leopard or line you see the three
lobes and also if you think of your own
hand when you take paint in you pop it
in in the paint and you pop it on a
piece of paper then you also kind of
have two lobes at the bottom by your
wrists look at the legs crust yes you
are you are anyway sitting here for
longer of course because these guys are
just in the meantime let me send you up
to the masai mara wooden pad well we
were here with a front on elephant what
appears to be a lone bull but in a very
rude turn of events he has turned around
and faced his bottom towards us so
obviously it must be a little bit camera
shy
we just came across it grazing on the
side of the road right now I thought
well why not balance out the exciting
start with a little bit of mellowness
now I did move off from the oh we know
pride we were just having a bit of a
signal and comms issues there and they
had also gone quite flat after their
efforts so I probably will circle back
through them and just check in later
because there's one of two things that
could happen they may go back to hunt
and they also may they also sorry by the
nut it may also lead us to her cub again
if she has stashed it but right now I'm
held up in a bit of a roadblock
it's the best roadblock it to be and
though we can see a little bit of drivel
coming out to your pending there hey
showing us a little bit of attitude
look at that those eyes the other day
when we had that or yeah yesterday
morning well yeah it was it was
yesterday morning I've had so many cool
so I think lately TWiki say his love is
ring whose yes the wrinkles are great
around that eye and yesterday morning
when we had a very close-up encounter
with those elephants I was just staring
into the eye and it was almost seemed
like it was staring at right back at me
one was actually giving me a little bit
of attitude and I just sat there and
looked at it and I am definitely making
this up I'm sure this wasn't actually
the case but it's nodded at me
and then walked off calmly so it was
almost as if it checked me out and then
just gave me a nod to say hey you're a
rat mate keep moving I think I'm just a
few min izing the elephant's nice nice
little sighting there it's always good
to have Elly's thrown into the mix we
know quite a lot of ground birds on this
road as well we just went past a whole
heap of guinea fowl and there was a
redneck despair fell just down here but
has disappeared into the grass I was
going to show you but
gone gone but yeah so and then a Corky
Franklin is low so later lots of ground
birds around to this afternoon
all right well I think that we are going
to head up north and potentially try to
find it cheetah cubs not making any
promises but that is the plan in the
meantime let's go back down to South
Africa and see what is going on down
there we've here with the scuba Steven
snorkel Sarah and a funny things just
happened there was two Egyptian geese
they were peddling their little legs or
swimming and they swam straight towards
the hippos and the hippos submerged and
when the two keys got to the middle the
two hippos popped up and it was a rather
scary moment for the two Egyptian geese
they seem to have moved off a little bit
and they sort of waiting for the heart
palpitations to get back to a normal
rate and then they'll probably carry on
swimming but it was a rather silly thing
for them to do and they could see that
the hippos were there and they just swam
straight to Walden so Steven Sarah -
resident hippos at the before sock dam
and a male and a female the male bigger
one of the two and then the female so it
looks like okay Steve on the left there
on the right we call them snorkeling
scuba because they spend so much time
under the water so when a hippo decides
that he wants to submerge himself he's
got the capabilities to spend at least
about 6 minutes
underneath the water and if they want to
move
they generally then walk across the
bottom but where they are now they're
not floating they're standing where they
are so all they have to do is just lift
the head up open their nostrils taking a
nice deep breath and then they can put
their head down again it's been quite a
warm day so that's why they're still in
the water when it starts when the Sun
Goes Down and it starts getting a little
bit cooler that's when they'll think
about moving on to go and find some
grass walking out the water
for you bird lovers out there we've got
also a blacksmith left wing to the right
on the edge of the water I'm just I've
just heard that there's a question
coming I'm waiting for it
so what is the gestation period of the
hippo someone from the universe child
from the universe apologies I've still
got to get all those handles so the
gestation period of hippo quite
interestingly is actually only 8 months
and you would think Wow
why so short for an animal so large
because you compare them to an animal
relatively the same size like a rhino
female white rhino about 16 months and a
hippo only 8 months but the development
of the calf is pretty quick because they
have the comfort of being in the water
so that sort of the buoyancy of the
water the calf is quite small it is very
tiny when it comes out or only weighing
a couple of kilos when she gives birth
what she'll do she won't give birth in
the water generally close to the
shallows to the edge where she's able to
push the calf to the edge of the water
so that it can take its first breath and
at that point she'll be extremely
protective of that young calf she
doesn't allow any of the other hippos to
close by and she even wouldn't allow
even other animals or people to approach
her that would be when they would get
really really aggressive and then if she
needs to take it to deeper water
obviously the calf is tiny so it almost
sinks to the bottom it almost has to
bounce off the bottom to come up to take
a breath of it sometimes in the day
you'll actually find a hippo cough lying
on the back of the mother so that it can
stay in the safety and the security of
the deeper water but it doesn't have to
struggle so much to bob up and down in
the water
so that would always be a hope that we
have a baby a part of these two in the
near future so another tool animal that
has a very long gestation period would
be a giraffe and that's gonna tell you a
little bit about that yes very long
gestation period indeed does the Masai
giraffe giraffe a tipple scre Chi so yet
another mammal along this Drive
something intimate and close up again
it's been very cool cool little
experience so far now these ones are
being absolutely harassed by some
oxpeckers you can see them on this one's
neck here but there was another one who
neck was absolutely thick with him and
was shaking its head around running
about the poor and being had just looked
absolutely devastated it was swarmed by
these little fellas see going about
their business there it looks like they
are picking something off the giraffe I
can only assume it ticks but they also
may be going up for the blood underneath
the ticks as well giraffe is very happy
with me right now yes sir I think every
time I find giraffes in our draft gal it
can just be dedicated to you because I
always come across them by chance
whenever I say I'm going to find one for
you I always end up well sometimes I
find them but other times I haven't been
able to show them because it's infrared
range and all that jazz so yes every
time I find your ass now giraffe girl
you can be sure that it is for you he's
poor poor giraffe toy box peckers all
over them I could only imagine that
would be quite annoying
this definitely was the other one so we
actually surrounded by them we don't
only have them on the right ear there is
many on the left as well so they are all
around the road I mean not the road all
on the side of the road right now
soaking that the piece of Amar of damara
after seeing a couple of hunts over the
last couple of days it's been very
exciting stuff actually following these
the wee nose around I've really grown to
love them and get really started to get
to know them anyway continuing on
so my new was telling me that there is a
cheetah cubs stashed somewhere and we
are going to go and just have a look
around and see if we can actually find
them because wouldn't that be something
it's definitely something I didn't think
I don't think I would ever have seen so
if we could find them I would be over
the moon
but there is also plenty to see along
the Ray well I will continue on my
search for Cubs but it sounds like true
Sharla's that search for Cubs is already
complete and she has some cute little
hyenas to show you
speaking of cubs these two tiny ones
came out of the den just really really
cute I think these are June's two and
pretties to have scampered off with
quirky she started to call I think she
was calling for plonker you often hear
that
no she she does that when she wants to
call for him and even she doesn't into
the den and then that's when all the
Cubs come on so I think that she's going
to look for for plunk what is she's
calling plunk and then she had his two
little friends until
now ribbon is on the other side don't
have these two we'll go down to her one
seems to be trying but this one is a
little bit curious now I love when
they're really tiny and they have these
lines on their head and their forehead
and their eyes look so so cute it's just
totally innocent
earlier they got a bit of us pulled over
frightened what are they what are they
responding to and then we saw big
elephant bull the other side of the
dandiya was not interested in this area
at all but the Cubs freaked out everyone
says how cute I think they're stunning
absolutely stunning and those whole ears
unn unn tatted just just too cute
like little bears
sniff sniff sniff I need to learn
speaking of elephants we had lots of
sort of trees pushed over around here
and bits of dugout land and we thought
jeez if when the elephants come around
here if they've been here when it comes
out they would have had such a scare
I would love to see what a couple do it
sees a big elephant fuse you guys are
asking if these and June's on ribbons
come so you know I was actually thinking
the same thing I haven't seen ribbons
caps yet and you didn't know that they
came out as she joined at the den when I
had when I was on leave and now when I
look at these two one definitely looks
younger or darker than the other but
then also you know coats change in spots
coming in at different times so I can't
be sure
now we do know that ribbon is on the
other side but the Cubs have been gone
to her so maybe these are June's Cubs
and will soon see I mean if they go to
the ribbon and they suckle then we'll
know for sure that their ribbons comes
oh if June comes and joins us then we'll
know
but since I've been back I haven't seen
ribbons I've only seen pretties to plunk
of course and then June's too if you
guys know and you've taken pictures of
these Cubs and you know there's their
spots then let me know because I would
love love to know exactly who's who in
the zoo use that hashtag Safari live
please let me know
how's that side glance
that's so cute because it's similar
sitting similarly to how Corky was sort
of on that Michael you say these are
June's Cubs that did suspect so I think
ribbons Cubs would be smaller and darker
so I would suspect so hey you two
growing up so fast
all is listening around to the bush
oops what's got your attention
it's nice and cool now so that's
probably why coqu's moved off maybe
she's taken the two two little ones with
her or I say taken but they college it's
followed her and she didn't have enough
in her to shoo them enough but maybe
they will bring back clunk and she will
carry on hunting it's a nice time of day
it's cooler
I think I might move around to where
ribbon was and just have a look at her -
Janet you'd like to know if I think that
these comes at then or if they look like
they haven't been fed well I kind of
know what you mean
I know what you mean they look a bit a
bit gangly oh they do but I wonder if
that's just the phase of growth that
they in because you'll find that the
legs will grow and then the rest of the
body kind of needs to catch up the ears
go rigs legs will grow and they look a
bit disproportionate so we'll see or
have a better look but I don't I don't
think they're too bad to be honest
and when did we see June last I
definitely saw at the den the last time
I was here and she would have fed them
no I think you're okay little one
okay they've moved over to the other
side let's see ribbon is there let's go
visit her in the meantime let me send
you over to da drain which is doing some
who is doing something we do a lot
so I believe there's quite a few
questions and answers expected so fire
away
Wow so magic dragon is asking what is my
favorite place to guide I'd probably say
the Kruger National Park and that's
based on being one of the largest areas
in South Africa to guide in and I see
when I started my career as a guide I
was very young as I said it was 18 I was
driving a big Safari vehicle for like 20
people so we didn't really get out the
vehicle or do anything but over the
years to be able to be in foot in one of
these last big wilderness areas of South
Africa has been really really awesome
and the best part about guiding is the
fact that every day is different you
just never know what you're gonna get
next
Christiaan from Bob have I seen mountain
gorillas I have in fact seen mountain
gorillas that was a lifetime dream to go
and see them so last year up in Uganda
in the Windy impenetrable forest very
fortunate enough to go and if anyone is
ever thinking about going doing gorillas
do it it's a must it's the most
incredible you only get an hour but it
is the most incredible hour that you get
to spend with them we were so fortunate
we had a troop of about 21 large
silverback variety of inference from
nine months old all the way up to adult
females and just the sheer interaction I
couldn't believe that an animals so
large we could see so close that was
relatively undisturbed by our presence
that just they just they just did their
thing and towards the end of the hour
they landed up in a nice open clearing
and we had 14 gorillas in an open
clearing and the big silverback was in
the middle he pulled over a large stump
and they were picking with their fingers
in that rotting stump for all the grubs
in the Lavi so absolute must Bob if it's
on your bucket list do it
so the next question sorry I didn't get
the handle there but do I enjoy bush
walks and tracking absolutely and if all
goes well I'll be joining Jamie on a
bush walk tomorrow morning so will
absolutely see you what type of tracks
we can find we have been looking for
some this afternoon we've actually just
found a very interesting thing if one of
the mud pans is a random egg that was
just deposited on the side of the pan
and there wasn't too much evidence
around to suggest who left it there but
certainly a nice
parcel for the next monitor lizard that
comes along
we might be lucky we're heading into a
view into the west spatial clouds might
be might be a very nice sunset this
evening just have a look at those clouds
and while we do this little bit of a
rainbow on the lift and while we do that
you can head on to T'Challa with the
trishula sorry yeah with the hyenas
I'm sure it will be a beautiful sunset
this afternoon this morning was one of
the most stunning sunrises I've ever
seen there was a huge layers of mist and
then the Sun popped out like a golden
ball from behind them it was stunning
much like you ribbon yes it's a sleepy
day at the hanging it in everyone's just
kind of keeping trying to keep their
eyes open
and you see all these depressions
they've created even she's sitting in
one oh who was that you saw the moment
of collapse
bumblebee you'd like to know if there
are albino hyenas the possibility exists
I'm sure but I would think it's more
likely that someone would see a
leucistic hyena and I know that French
saw a leucistic hyena in the Mara so
that would be really really interesting
in fact it'd be great to see a picture
of that because I don't know if you guys
have noticed but pretties bigger Cup
looks really really pale so it'd be
interesting to know if maybe that could
be a logistic Cup though everything else
is fairly fairly dark eyes are still
very dark so I don't think so but I
think that would be really cool and I'd
really like to see a logistic iana
imagine imagine an albino hyena the
light white hyena it look like like a
spotty you will feel things very cute I
think maybe blue eyes like husky don't
be nice but no not here in gym I
definitely not change humour but brent
was lucky enough in the Mara to see that
as I'm sure you all though those type of
trades being Alvino or logistic or
melanistic you are still the exact same
species it just means that you are
carrying the recessive gene for
basically increasing your production of
melanin or inhibiting it in some way
that's how you have lice or white lions
there leucistic lions
there's lots of animals I'd like to see
that uh that would be leucistic
do you know any leucistic hyenas Ruben
said oh no
I think you know something like crowd
boo
child of the universe you'd like to know
when the last time I saw a hyena that
was not part of the Juma clan was well
like we were discussing earlier I have
only seen Juma clan hyenas I've not seen
anyone that is from outside sort of the
can and from what we know
hyena territories especially or
specifically to the Kruger can be about
150 kilometers squared so that is that
is a big big space and I think that's
that's something that's more more
appropriate for a bigger clan so I don't
think that this clan occupies that kind
of space I really don't think so but
that being said I haven't seen other
hyenas around members of other clans
around
like I said Jamie has seen it when there
was an elephant carcass not too far from
here but I'm not sure even when that was
must have been a while ago
okapis where have you gone
I thought they were going to go fetch
plunk but
you know it's really bad to make
promises that you may not keep but I
have faith in Pat he says that he
promises so let's go over to him and see
what he promises to give you this drive
I did not promise I specifically said as
soon as I said I was looking for cheetah
cubs and I'm not making any promises but
anyway so we are in the area now I've
been told to keep my eyes out from
anywhere here on out so I will be
searching a lot while I am talking so
you may not get all the eye contact in
the world but I do have two extra pairs
of eyes with me Manu and our Ascari on
the back so all is well we have a 22
look for
so were the cheetah cubs be unreal to
see I I can't even I don't think I've
actually even seen a video or a picture
of them so to see them in the flesh
would be unreal but I'm not going to
hide things up there too much and just
yet
slow down and have a bit more of a scam
it doesn't seem to be a whole lot of
anything around here which may make
citing an animal a little bit easier the
grass is a little bit shorter around
here but still cover could easily easily
hide away in here
so speaking of cheetah Bruce ara finally
got herself a killer I'm sure you all
have heard that I was a very happy TV
about myself
Christie what is my favorite baby animal
to see
well I very very much love lion cubs
[Music]
yeah yeah I think lion cubs I mean
puppies I also love puppies as low
they're hard to knock what other baby
animals have I seen they've been
absolutely cute I think I saw a baby yes
it was Baby Jaguar in a Costa Rica in
one of the rehabilitation centers I went
to it that was a super super cute so
that was definitely up there as well
but I think all babies are quite cute
now everybody just bear with me we're
just gonna have a chat to this Ranger
and see if he has any information on on
these cheetah cubs so just hang on one
second and well all right well I'm gonna
link it to DJ well I have it decent yet
how's it going look what I found two
little Easter bunnies it is a little bit
early for Easter but they're also out
early this is to scrub hair which is
quite strange you normally see them when
the lights have gone down but they have
obviously decided that they're coming
out early to get a quick bite eat who
knows they may even be on a date so what
good stretch there he's just warming up
his legs there in case any predator like
Columba comes along because that's his
defense is his speed so very long legs
and that's the big difference between
hares and rabbits rabbits generally tend
to have pretty short legs and his have
nice long legs for running so you can
see both of them just nibbling away
there at the fish grasses or nice grass
shoots there's been recently good rains
so they'll be eating the nice little
fresh shoots that come out
also having a look at their very large
pink ears and that helps them just like
elephants have got large ears that helps
them thermoregulate so they'll actually
use a very thin membrane and if you look
closely you can see even the blood
vessels in the ears and of course the
ears are for hearing they need to be
able to hear if there's any predators
sneaking up on him it's also very nice
to see two of them you don't often get
that sometimes
a scrub here is literally a flesh across
the road and they disappear
you also notice a big white white ring
around the eye and that'll aid them in
moving around in the dark so if any of
the available light will reflect on that
white around the eye and it'll actually
enhance what they're they're seeing the
one obvious he didn't like the the other
one being in the way and stealing his
grass patch so we're gonna move on and
we're gonna just keep on making our way
back towards the king Ghana to see if
he's doing anything else other than
sleeping but we have a little bit of a
ways to go so we're gonna carry on and
see what's there
sun'll I carry is asking the question of
do I have a least favorite animal Wow I
would probably say a snake and the only
reason I would say a snake is an
altercation once and it was a spitting
cobra that decided it didn't like me
inspect me in my eye so me and that
particular individual snake have a bit
of a beef but otherwise snakes in
general I do respect them but that
particular one
definitely not
so we as it's getting a little bit
cooler we're actually hoping that tingly
is actually going to do some movement
maybe some grooming you might be
stretching you might think if he
actually still has some remains of a
kill he might decide to make his way
back to their Kilner who knows cross
your fingers and maybe we get to see
that yeah he definitely hasn't been
anywhere further than the pen for the
whole day but one never knows
so I love snacks is asking if I went
blind temporarily after the Cobra I was
very fortunate in that because I done
quite a lot of training I knew that the
first thing to do after I'd been spat in
the eyes was to rinse my eyes as much as
possible so I spent about 20 minutes
literally with my eyes being forced open
under a water bath not a pleasant
experience but then again the venom the
venom in you eyes thought of his and
experience either so the importance was
just to flush it out and then very very
strong eye drops with some steroids in
him definitely did the job and a little
bit light-sensitive for a day or two but
then otherwise right as rain I was also
fortunate in that I didn't get a full
blow of venom to the eyes it was just
I almost it was like a slo-mo I saw it
coming and as I turned my head it got
more in the left eyelid in the right eye
but a scary thing nonetheless you do
have lots of thoughts that run through
your head at that time it was pretty
close it could have even bitten me as
well so yeah you got your heart
palpitations going and you've got to
some serious stress and especially
because you're living out in the bush in
the middle of nowhere
you are quite far from severe like
proper medical attention so it would
have been a pretty interesting
experience had it actually bitten me but
as I say lucky to be here today
so we're not finding too much at the
moment so I believe Trish has a herd of
elephants
yes we had a small roadblock and how
they've moved off and exactly where we
wanted them to be look at this wonderful
hood there's nothing better than seeing
elephants playing around in the water
because he's trying actually he's
actually drinking with his mouth so they
weigh down there we go there we go
Jemaine we have a list - of soft drink
you have a child
oh I am loving the elephants nurses are
moving and having the luck with the
elephants lately I have to agree and I
am loving it absolutely loving it now
look at the comparison you can see the
adult next next to the baby big cow is
it the way that she is drinking and
using her trunk and the way that she can
has complete control look at the babies
but little to no control step trunk
getting in your way that's what it looks
like
put a mouth spell so so cute
if we just you know the shape that yes
exactly that the shape of the trunk
going into the mouth once they've all as
they're drinking is just so beautiful I
love that shape
this is actually a nice kind of way to
see this you can see the home of herd is
moving off and in front there are a few
big big cows there and what will usually
happen is as the head moves the
matriarch or one of the bigger cars will
take the front and then one of the other
bigger ones will take the backs and all
the smaller and more vulnerable
individuals are in the middle between
them beautiful
I just listen you can hear them in kids
who just
the user gathered bearded woodpecker
doing his territorial John did it
addicted
what a lovely spectacular scene
[Music]
I just love it absolutely just love it
can you sit and watch you don't even
have to say anything they just speaks
themselves what they are moving up so I
think I will do the same cruise around
some more and see what we can find
now I heard that the wild dogs may have
crossed so we gonna check that out and
the meantime let me send you over to
pack to the Masai Mara
well I'm playing a little bit of
follow-the-leader here we came across
this a black it back to Jaco in front of
me and it was sniffing at some dung in
the road and I got very close to it and
it just didn't seem to want to move and
then it finally did move and then
stopped again and pretty much ever since
it's just been chugging along in front
of us just not not wanting to move I'm
not sure what it's playing is here but
it's yeah lady it's on a bit of a
journey this little cana form where are
you taking me are you taking me to the
cheetah cubs
Kirsten seems to think that this one is
going to lead me to the cheetah cubs I
did get a bit of an update from the
Rangers so I'm just turning back around
to go to where they said it was seen it
this morning
I thought they told me that they haven't
seen it in a long time but they were
saying that they haven't seen of me in a
long time because they thought I was one
of our old safari life presenters Scotty
D that's not actually the first time
that's happened that funnily enough as
well but still looks alright let's move
thanks mate what's your plan what are
your motives don't come closer every
time I think it's gonna move it just
comes back yeah in front of me there we
go
thank you thank you quite a cool little
animal the black back jakku
they have actually remained unchanged or
virtually unchanged in two-and-a-half
million years so that actually is a
testament to their success as a species
it's a very a long time
so I'm just back tracking there was a
different path I was told to take
apparently they were seen under a tree
this morning now I have to confess I do
not know a whole heap about cheetah cubs
so I'm not sure whether there would be
have moved up from this morning or not
but it is worth going at to check I
definitely think so just bear with me
one second so was it left yeah
it's great having some Rangers out here
who are very nice people always happy to
help out we always share our tips with
each other and locations of animals it
helps well it helps benefit both of us
really which is good it's always good to
have good relationships out here with
everyone it's not hard to do everyone is
so lovely in the Maasai Mara so nice
sure wants to know if I could be an
animal what animal would I be I reckon
I'd be an octopus I think leaving the
life oh maybe actually if lot if octopus
had a longer longevity I would
definitely say so most cephalopods don't
live to be older than 1 or 3 years but
jeez it would be cool to be an octopus
they can do it so much and they can fit
in such small spaces change their color
change their size so yeah I'd probably
say an octopus and now also I forgot to
add baby elephants in the question I was
asked earlier about my favorite baby
animals elephants as well I don't know
how I went over that yeah they are just
the best the best the air being an
octopus would be unreal I reckon they
are very a clever very intelligent
cephalopods do have two hemispheres to
their brains just like humans which is
pretty cool and three hearts well at
least it's squid there are three hearts
I feel like I'm back on dive life right
now anyone who doesn't know I did it
used to present for our sister show
called the dive live which was the same
concept as Safari live except underwater
it was a very very cool
so I'm just keeping an eye on all of
these trees hoping hoping hoping to see
a little cubby bait I hope you're all
enjoying your drive with Deidre as well
today
Monica wants to be a fish eagle so she
can fly all day so sorry I'm just
getting directions here from maroon yes
being a fish eagle would be great or any
type of bird especially I would think
that soaring the thermals would be great
it would be so much fun I want more so
yes I could definitely see why you would
get that answer I would also like to be
a stop as well because dolphins are
obviously highly intelligent highly
social creatures and they have the most
fun out in the ocean I have been out in
waves with dolphins also surfing at the
waves with me so yeah being able to be a
dolphin and still have the ability to
surf would be a sick as well no excuse
my colloquialism there it would be great
as well
ah sorry there's some track see
let's link to dear Dre I do apologize
for that dear Dre not dear dree I'm
sorry let's link to you
so while pets are still searching his
heart here Petter would like to be an
octopus well I certainly on a day like
today could do with an octopus for
having eight arms to go in all different
directions one to drive one to change
gears one to look at the camera one to
hold the spotlight later it's certainly
I want to operate the radio it's
certainly is done whatever would I like
to be well I'm thinking an eagle and the
only reason I say an eagle was if you
could maybe you could travel places you
could visit different areas and clock up
some frequent flying miles maybe a
migratory one as well like a steppe
Eagle you could really have the best of
both worlds some are in two different
hemispheres I think that that's not a
bad plan we're still on our way to 10
Ghana we are nearly there it looks like
we're going to be in for an awesome
sunset so definitely stick around for
that
meena moves asking do I have a favorite
bird of prey well I'd have to say a
secretary bird probably more likely to
see them up at the Mara with Pat maybe
he can show you one in the next day or
so
but secretary bird just for that
beautiful plume of feathers that card at
the back of the head that beautiful red
coloration around the eye and then also
their hunting habits I did happen to see
a secretary bird hunting once was the
stalking through the graphs waiting to
flush things and it happened to flush a
grasshopper and of course they run on
over and he tried once to stomp it but
he missed and the grasshopper flew again
and he looks like a rather funny chicken
running chasing after this grasshopper
and the second time it landed he made
sure of his aim and he stomped at one
shot and that was his breakfast so
definitely a secretary bird would be one
of my favorite Raptors Mina move what
would be yours you can answer me on
hashtags for reliable in the column
column the comment column
with the with the almost 10,000 birds in
the world it is really a different
difficult choice to pick a favorite but
yeah other reason for being an eagle is
just they have such phenomenal eyesight
so you could be flying high up and see
awesome things so I didn't get the
question there I heard it was about long
eyelashes but I'm not 100% sure what
there's lots of bears with long
eyelashes and it was the ground humbles
have got long eyelashes
from pan would like to see a southern
ground horn ball funny story this
morning we were driving along and we saw
some birds and we stopped to look at
birds and somebody made a comment
AFER's you can move on so the very next
thing we see is two grand humbles this
morning that actually did fly up so
they're here so stay tuned
maybe we'll get them on Safari probably
more in the morning and there's a chance
to see them and as they flew off
I quickly said to the guy oh don't worry
about those we can move on of course I
was joking ground Wombles being very
rare and endangered or certainly a
species that you'd want to stop and have
a good look at there's so few of them I
do know that that is a big tick for
quite a few people so we do were about
to head in and have a look at ting Ghana
he seems to be in the same place
but before we get there you are gonna
hit across sir to treasurer trishula
that has a beautiful sunset
I have a stunning stunning sunset this
afternoon look at that just between
those branches affected knobs on
stunning
there is really nothing like the African
sunset or the African sunrise so intense
it's like you're here guys
[Music]
standing and there's a mountains behind
behind the sunset as well look at those
mountains so so nice those are the
Drakensberg mountains are part of
drakensberg mountains which is biggest
mountain range in South Africa and it
extends from mattel which is where I'm
from all the way up this is the northern
section the section I'm used to is the
seventh section would you think about
things like you know to go home for me
see it feels like so many hours of
traveling to drive would be 11 hours or
something like that and look at these
mountains they can stretch all this way
in no time
well I heard from a little birdie that
there's a surprise for you waiting up in
the Maasai Mara with Patrick so let me
not waste your time and send you right
over one Kabat that we can see in the
grass so I just wanna you know keep it
it's solid distance but I still wouldn't
mind which I move did you think yeah I'm
just gonna creep around
this is great
there it is
so we did just say these two e cheaters
sitting up out of the grass well right
we were actually led by the black-backed
jackal I'll just move around a little
bit further so we can get a better view
sorry it's just a bit difficult in it's
a long grass I don't want to get too
close either ah honestly I wasn't
expecting us to find them well yeah I
mean I was obviously hoping but I didn't
actually fully fully expect this what a
day it has been oh so good yeah so
there's actually a couple of black pack
of jackals or cheetahs yep chasing it
off being defensive there they are
actually they maybe wanted the Cubs for
themselves it's really hard to get an
angle here I do apologize we can see the
bit of defense there though against
those black-backed jackals they were
actually kind of helped us find the
cheetah even even still just finding
cheetahs is is just great
jeez I've been lucky there's a drive
completely lucky
I'm sure we all heard that would be the
barking from the jackals they sure
that's about four jackals in the grass I
think they might want to take this I
think they were trying to get duck hugs
but be the parental effort they're very
good
capture them away focus there there's a
caucus there's a caucus ah okay ah so
they have a carcass with them so that's
what the jackals are after I see yeah ah
very good so these tree to have made a
kill so here I'm just going to stay
quiet for a second the Jackals are still
making some noise
so now I'm starting to think if the Cubs
are actually here I'm sure we saw a
smaller face in the grass I said calm on
the Left I think there is a couple more
left
mm-hmm yeah so bundled yeah oh so bad oh
okay
okay so yeah very cool sighting here
carcass cheetah and some jackals to come
in and take what I actually say I could
only assume it would be a Thomson's
gazelle or some small antelope that they
have but as I said this a tall grass is
making it a bit difficult just move
around a little bit further so you get
better angle
so I was expecting cab cubs but it's
actually just a yes a sub-adult how's
that good cool so this one is really
showering down here
now I'm not sure as to the
identification of these cheetahs
obviously this one here is a relatively
new one and I can just see the back of
the mother's head right in there so I
can't really yeah
if anyone could ID that they would be
awesome well it's it seems like I'm not
the only one who has found spotted cats
it seems like DJ DJ DJ is having an
awesome drive and has found herself a
resetted cat so you're not the only one
that's found spotted guess he has just
got up we are with him at exactly the
right time as I predicted earlier
heading to the waterhole we're just
gonna wait for him to move past and then
what we're gonna do is probably see him
drinking and he was alert because they
were Franklin's alarming in the bush
earlier which might well mean that is
potentially a hyena or something else
that chooses me you might still have a
kill somewhere and they might have seen
the Predators I know this is gonna be
I'm just gonna reverse because the pen
is just behind us Jamie's gonna let me
know if ting gone is too close I can
just see his spots through the back of
the vehicle so this is going to be
awesome so one very thirsty cat with a
gorgeous sunset in the background
and there is as you watch they don't
drink water like we do you actually see
they lap it up so they're literally
almost sticking their tongue in and then
bringing it up and catching them if
belly is so full and he's been eating
though dude drink more more more
obviously get the prey that is eaten but
also aid with the process of digestion
so we'll sit with him know
maybe you can get that in audio because
very often you get that yeah they're
lapping
just imagine if you choose to come on to
the wild earth expeditions you could be
sitting right in this position right now
next to the sunset lifting corner
drinking water just like that so at the
end of the show have a look at wild
earth dot TV /x tradition is a book your
space now seats are selling faster
he is thirsty boy
you actually see just by the way sitting
you can see there's strong muscles and
the shoulders and in the arms even in
the hind legs and you can actually see
how thick his neck is and being a big
male leopard it allows him to take
relatively large prey of up a tree
chincana wouldn't worry too much about
scrub hair
they probably too small for him he
prefers to eat much larger prey and
sometimes it's effort versus roared that
they have to consider
huh how much do you think he's been
drinking
Faye's asking the question can animals
get sick from drinking dirty water they
can particularly in the dry season
especially if the water levels have got
very very low in their certain levels of
bacteria and like a blue-green algae and
cyanobacteria they can get too sick from
that but fortunately for a lot of the
Predators they actually have very very
strong stomach acids so that'll actually
aid in possibly killing off some of that
bacteria I've even seen lepers in the
desperation of the dry season drinking
out of the smallest muddiest footprint
puddle and you go with what you've got
he's about to move
you see he's he's old Loompas
resurrected itself and it may come from
having to cook he move up the tree maybe
you was chased by he know and he had to
hoist his kill a lot faster than he was
comfortable with and maybe it's just a
little bit inflamed but as we said oh
now he is getting on a bit and that's
one of these things
possibly going to st. mark there he
starts just scratching his back feet and
then little Jets of urine will come out
while he's leaving his scent behind for
the male leopards because it was raining
quite a lot yesterday afternoon well
yesterday morning should I say and
marking their territory is pretty much
first and foremost on their list of
things to do because the rains washed
away all this in marking what a
beautiful cat definitely why they one of
my favorites
you don't even hear him walking away
from us just puts those feet down so
quietly so he flicks out his front paws
and his back feet almost go into the
same position walking quietly so there
is another vehicle with us in the
sighting so we are gonna try and follow
him stay with him hopefully he's leading
us back to where his killers
we as we follow him it's gonna be a
little bit difficult II might go through
some thick bush and we're gonna head
over to Trish Allah
move best of luck getting through that
thick bush there's nothing like having
to follow an animal to the bush
especially when they get up and they're
ready to go on the hunt go on a search
and they're on a mission they know where
they're going it's not as if they're
looking for a spot of shade to lie down
and so it is quite difficult I often
find myself panting sometimes remember
once I followed husana through
half-hearted attempt to catch a scrub
here
but even that a half-hearted attempt for
scrub hair got me panting because you'd
turn this way no turn this way oh
there's a stump oh he's on his side it
can be crazy but I'm sure DJ will do
just fine well I have confirmation that
the dogs have crossed into puffles hook
which is another area just north of us
that we can't go and drive onto so
unfortunately but you know what dogs
they go back and forth so often and they
can be tomorrow in the Sun sunrise
Safari they may very well be back which
would be cool
I have the question if I could be an
animal what animal would that be it
sounds like a riddle almost there's so
many I am the worst person to be asked
this question though I would I would
really like to be a bird which but I
don't mind too much but I would really
like to be a bird so then I could fly
and but then I'd also really like to be
a spider because I just think that's
that would be amazing have many eyes as
you guys know I wear contact lenses so
to have imagine having eight eyes that
all work perfectly that would be amazing
although I don't think I'm so keen on
the hairiness or the eight limbs for our
Halloween party at camp last year I I
came as a spider I did that's how much I
liked them a green pea spider that would
be cute I like the green pea spiders I
think I think I'd make a think I'd make
a good spider and then I'd be able to
build my house out of myself your
expenses would be so low you're catching
water in your web no water bills no
electricity bones yeah I'd say a spider
definitely
what was the other question that you
know yesterday you guys are asking about
who we who the guys would like to take
and drive with them I wasn't on drive
but III do have a preference I would
love to take roger federer on drive with
me he is I think I must be one of his
biggest fans I absolutely love tennis
and Roger Federer for me none better
than he is and plus his mom South
African so maybe he might come to South
Africa and come for safari yeah who
knows and Jamie answered David
Attenborough but slightly on the fence
and I won't say I totally agree with her
I would love to have David Attenborough
as well but totally on the fence because
I'd feel so much pressure to have
everything perfect even though I know
that he's like you know almost like that
wonderful gentle giant uncle but I'd
feel so much pressure to get everything
perfect so I'm gonna stick with Roger
Federer hopefully you'll come along and
visit and I can take him on Drive then
we could play some tennis that'd be cool
too
so we were looking for a few tracks
leopard tracks to be exact that may that
Jamie had said that she had seen along
that road that we were just on but now
with the light being so poor I couldn't
see too much
Lauren that is such an interesting
question you want to know in light of
st. Patrick's Day if they are animals
besides group besides green besides
birds that have green in them they are
and green is a really really interesting
color or interesting pigment in nature
because green is not particularly
prevalent and not it's not particularly
prevalent because the pigment associated
with green is not common and obviously
we see it in plants all around us the
green but that green is because of
chloroplasts the chlorophyll that's in
the color plus everything else all the
other wavelengths are being absorbed in
the Greens getting reflected which is
what we see and the same applies for
birds birds don't usually contain a
green pigment besides Tarak O's which
are a certain type of bird so besides
turquoise know another of the other
green birds that you would know like the
green pigeon actually contains green
pigment just like a snake and other
reptiles that have green in them or like
the green pea spider that is not
actually pigment those are different
layers that are creating that color and
then the reptiles is particularly
interesting because you have sort of
three layers of cells in their in their
skin or their dermis and they have
Milano falls at the bottom and that
creates the darkness or the lightness
depending on whether they constrict it
or make it big and then you have sort of
an iridescent cell which will reflect
the right in light in different ways to
create different colors and then you get
your chromatophores which are another
set of cells and those cells have red
and yellow and then they a combination
of those are used to create green green
is not actually a pigment that is
available in many many animals so I
think that's it's actually quite a
strange thing to think about especially
when you when you think Green is so so
common for us and I love green I really
do
very very cool question yeah I think
Greenpeace spider insects I mean lots of
other insects beetles as well lots of
them with green on it and it's an
illusion how cool is that
anyway I'm gonna keep on driving along
see what else I can find
still feeling excited about what I could
find him having a good day in the
meantime let's go over to deer drain
with that wonderful ting gana so this is
the duke of the North East Duke of
Zoomer sorry he's basically been walking
walking slowly and leisurely up the road
doing his nightly business st. marking
on the trees smells just like popcorn
but definitely not the same kind of
popcorn that my dog Bella likes this is
they exactly the smell of freshly popped
popcorn is what the male's urine on the
tree yes smells like so obviously ting
Ghana's been busy drinking quite a lot
of water that helps and he's now taking
a complete left turn so he's walked all
the way on the road to take a left turn
so obviously he didn't feel like walking
through the block through all the grass
he's walking on the roads that's typical
for them because often they use the
roads as the territorial boundaries so
he has been marking and we just keep
following him now that he's warmed up a
little bit it seems like that limp is
gone
willing a bit more comfortably so yeah
quite like here st. mark again you see
they're just kicking back as I've got
st. glens between their feet so that
also allows them to leave scent on the
ground
so that's his calling card any other
territorial mail will know that he's
still here he's still dominant if they
want to pick a fight he's here and he's
ready he may even decide to start
calling that's really awesome to hear
when they have that sawing like wood
sander makes a really awesome sound here
at night on
that's a calling card that
so I didn't copy that I see we hoping
that Tigana is going walking towards
Killa but he seems to be taking his time
about it so now they waiting for
tingoora to call me too I'm also waiting
for him to call hopefully have blood and
insult him with buy a fake leopard call
of my rasping sound he generally also do
it by facing down into the ground and
he'd called pretty much every 15 minutes
or so I'm just to announce his territory
if he's looking for a female that's also
the way that the females are gonna find
him so she'd find him by finding one of
his territorial markings she'd urinate
on top of that if she was interested in
looking to him for breeding and then she
would start calling and he obviously
been the territorial male would then
want to find her so if he's in pursuit
of a female he may then land up calling
a lot at shorter intervals more
regularly follow him
under a perfect almost half moon sir
already starting to get dark he's going
to a tree so he might actually lift his
tail now and cinmarc against the tree I
doubt he'll climb the tree he generally
would do that to fees got the kill up
there I don't see it in that Marilla no
he just did a quick st. mark and he's on
the move again so territorial males like
him they can have very large territories
over ten square kilometers generally
based on the prey availability as well
as the competition so as he gets older
you might finally get squeezed by other
territorial males into a slightly
smaller territory but he has his
territory he'll defend from other males
but he has multiple different females
that'll live within his territory
look how as it gets darker he's just
blending in even though he's going to
almost disappear into the grass and it's
time to go across to pet in the Mara and
just get an update on his spotted cats
the cheetahs
well it may be st. Patrick's Day but it
also is just Patrick's a day what a
incredible day this has been
it actually started out even this
morning Nikki and I was studying in the
studio or working in the studio I'm sure
you us at least some of you are aware of
the studio and two variable Sun birds
came and sat right in front of us on the
window so we were less than a meter less
than three feet away from them perched
up sitting there looking at very
beautiful then the lion hunt and now
some cheetah as well so James Richard to
the rescue he has told us that this is
no Serena which is Kenya's daughter and
narrow toys sister Syrian in a Syrian no
Syrian that's the one
no Syrian now it seems like the it's not
a cub that she has so I was expecting a
full-blown young cub but this one seems
to be around one-year-old maybe a little
bit less Manu said that he saw her about
or her or him about five months ago and
it was still about the same size that is
now a little bit bigger now so yeah so
it's still a sub-adult for sure but just
a little bit more grown up than I was
expecting but still absolutely stoked to
have come across this and they're
obviously keeping guard of a carcass so
they must have made a kill and I wonder
if the young was involved in helping out
with the kilt whether you know now
Syrian that did just do it herself
there we go there's a jackal waiting
patiently for them to move off so it can
come in and scavenge I'm actually
wondering whether anything else is going
to come in over the course of the night
as well we obviously saw earlier NASA an
Assyrian was being very protective of
the carcass and of her young keeping
those at jackal at bay now standing
proud they look yet very cool very cool
to be spending time with these ones Mary
she is a beauty I wholeheartedly agree
with you both of these cheetahs are so
gorgeous
you've probably heard a little bit of
crackling that was yeah just actually
let's all I'm going to spend a solid
minute of quietness and let's just enjoy
the beauty of this cheetah the sounds of
the night and hopefully if the young
starts feeling again we might even get
some crunching of some bones
it was feeding just a second ago
so I'm just trying to get a little bit
closer with my heads and therefore my
microphone to see if we can get this
answer
dragging its carcass along a student get
a proper look to see exactly what they
did manage to take down whatever it is I
think it's definitely ample I got a look
at the young ones at Bali before and
it's very full I've never seen such a
big belly on a cheetah in my life
definitely had it so a nice little feed
I actually read it the other day an
average adult cheetah will either think
about 2.6 kilograms of meat in a sitting
after a kill so that's in pounds about
five to six pounds maybe a little bit
more jackals still hanging on the
outskirts weighting it their chance to
come in maybe steal a little bit for
themselves obviously quite a bit smaller
than a cheater and wouldn't require as
much food so yeah
oh I'm hopeful that they leave a little
bit for you
rocky keys peace well this drive just
keeps getting better and better
was it
you know I salute interaction again I'm
just gonna stay quite so you can listen
to all these unfold
from the jack-in-the-box
what what what yeah yeah let's uh let's
do it unscheduled yeah this is very cool
sighting
welcome everybody to this a special
broadcast coming to you live from the
Masai Mara in Kenya we have a very
interesting scene here we have found a a
cheetah by the name of Miss Syrian and
young sub-adult and they have made a
kill and with a carcass but there are
black-backed jackals trying to get in at
the carcass and take a bit for
themselves so there's been a bit of a
dispute between the cheetah and the
Jackals it seems like one there has
gotten itself a little bit of carrion
yeah my name is Patrick joining me on
camera is Minerva if you have any
questions or comments about this
broadcast please use the hashtag Safari
live on Twitter or whatever jet stream
you're on let's get back into the action
sorry I'm gonna have to do a circle I
don't want to reverse just because I
can't see behind me and it is night time
I don't wanted to do anything to disturb
the animals so just bear with me for two
seconds
so it seems like the cheetah may have
retreated off the carcass is that was
that the other cheater or a jackal over
here to the left ah yes
so seems like the Jackals may have won
this one actually they have moved away
now I'm just gonna get my flashlight out
and see if I can relocate the carcass to
see if there is yeah okay so just to my
right we can see the Jackals have
managed to get themselves in Wow
incredible stuff absolutely incredible
so don't feel bad for the cheetah they
did get their field the little one was
snacking away for quite a while there
how crazy is this
well accolades to the jackals for the
point food and clothes you know he's
cheated off the mother was doing a great
job of keeping them away with being with
this carcass for about 20 minutes or
half an hour and the jackals had made a
few attempts to get towards it but every
time they got the chased off looks like
there may even be a little bit of
dispute amongst the Jackals themselves
Cathy I don't think the cheaters would
ever eat the Jackals would probably
prefer a nice at Thompson's gazelle
cheetah and jackals are both carnivores
so they will compete for food but they
will most likely not eat one another
perhaps in desperate situations if they
did come across a dead jackal
but I highly doubt it Kristin that is
very likely that all of that commotion
and noise made by the jackals could
bring in other scavengers it may have
been heard by some hyenas yes I through
think that it may throughout the night
have attracted some more attention and
so it will be interesting at UC at what
it does unfold over this carcass then
maybe yeah as I said some bigger hyenas
come through to chase the jackal off but
I didn't get to have a good look at the
carcass so I wasn't sure exactly what it
was I'm guessing it is a small antelope
of some sort so perhaps it might just be
enough to feed the jackal and it wasn't
pretty well it fed on as well while we
were with it but yes there is every
chance that the noise could attract
other scavengers throughout the night
so a little bit of knock enos going on
there between them I'll just move up two
wards at the caucus a little bit so we
can try and get a better look
Sally is happier for the Jackals that
they got some food is saying way to go
I'm actually kind of thinking the same
just because the cheaters did get a good
feeding I yeah it was a nice little win
to see actually I do love a black back
jackals if anybody was joining us in our
regular broadcast just before you were
the scene at the one though I was
following along the road they're such
brave animals they don't often run in
the face of danger and a very very
confident around bigger animals as we
just saw then
we have one that's just scampered off
I'm just gonna have a quick look and see
if I can see if the cheetah is still
inside okay so they are over there all
righty well
just
I'll just move a little bit closer so we
can see they're jackals actually feeding
and then I'll go back over to those
cheetah who just a little bit up the
road from it will not up the road up the
aftergrass from us
Lynne yes so cheetah are very wary of
other predators and definitely don't
want to be injured so she just really do
rely on their body and their speed stay
quite well this disabilities going on
but yes so they really do not want to
risk injury so you'll see they are very
timid towards other attacks especially
around carcasses and yeah they really do
rely on their body functioning it
normally in order to be able to make
survival for themselves to be able to
feed and move around find mates on water
so an injury out here can really really
can mean death in many cases for an
animal especially a delicate animal like
a cheetah they're not feel to like the
other big cats as I said they built the
speed rather than for power and strength
and so can be hurt quite easily
people often compare them through the
Ferraris at the cats in they're fast
agile but easy to wreck
so I can see those horns now this
definitely it does look to be a
Thomson's gazelle it is a very cool to
watch everyone it's been a great day
today for me that lion hunts elephants
giraffes and now this with cheetahs and
the jackals and jackals are taking over
the carcass for themselves absolutely
unbelievable started in the Maasai Mara
of Kenya yeah definitely it does seem to
be a little gazelle and I was wondering
earlier on whether both the cheetahs
were involved in the hunt or whether it
was just the older and more experienced
mother that took it down when we did
first arrive the young cheetah was
feeding on it
again I'm just gonna stay quiet let us
listen to this feeding
what's a lion is coming why he has come
in search as I was thinking I aim is
come to take over 300 acres now or Wow
they came out of nowhere Wow
how exciting is this jackals are still
trying to get back into it but those
hyenas came in it like a ton of bricks
just took over completely Wow so this
does just highlight the animal that
makes the kill isn't necessarily the
only one that feeds on it they'll be a
long list of other animals that come in
hyenas and jackals and vultures as well
of course in composition phase the whole
circle of life isn't it
I think another Heidi's grab another
light is coming down
snapping of those bones
- perhaps boys a very strong jaws and
very strong digestive systems crunch
that boner right there
jeez it must be busy work right there
trying to eat and eat others away from
your food at the same time sure the
energy expended the energy gained from
the food
what
[Music]
listen to have to be up there with one
of the best sightings I've ever had out
here than a Masai Mara
sorry cool
and I think the best thing of it all is
so far no one has been seriously hurt
none of the animals have copped an
injury from this it's not over yet
having said that he's still trying their
hardest to get in they're doing a good
job of defending no lorina yet same I do
love the jackals are so brave as well
it's just it's so cool to see such a
small animal stick up for themselves it
reminds me of the damselfish yesterday's
a small fish under water that will
aggressively defend their territory
against anything even other day even big
human divers that will come and charge
them even though they're probably no
longer than 10 to 15 centimetres about 5
to 6 7 inches long
as you know here use as well as I am
[Music]
yeah I'm sorry there are any sensitive
viewers watching this probably isn't the
best dina for user asked that he turn
away if that is the case this is just
nature don't hear things unfold out here
so heinous often it regards as
scavengers but they are not just
scavengers as well they are incredibly
intelligent creatures incredibly good at
problem-solving and working together as
a team and this combined with the fact
that are they are beat they can run for
a long time at 30 good speeds they make
them quiet good hunters as well as
scavengers but when they do see the
opportunity to take a meal they will
also do that to see them at bobbing
Aiden Lions and they have enough numbers
they'll take on wives or I kill
successfully take the kill from them as
well
just scanning again for the cheaters
so the cheater are nowhere to be seen
now everybody's saying our loving
hearing that noises oh so again I'm just
gonna let you all enjoy it
the battle for survival hey everyone
everything just doing whatever you can
to keep itself alive still just can't
believe this
sorry cool
Dasia is asking it do they tend to be
not so overly aggressive when there is
enough to share well yes in a way yes if
you'll know this the larger the Clippers
many more yes so I've actually even seen
hyena and a leopard being on the same
carcass without much conflict and I've
seen it with hyenas and lions as well
but I quite often in between species
there is generally always some form of
conflict after some time but between
species there will be a less conflict at
the more through two there is
as well about that inter intra species
of relationships just so cool to watch
it it's almost like watching a game it's
sport isn't it
no boys teams trying to use tactics
one that attacks one defends and the
prize well a bit of a meat in their
tummies it's like the jackals on the wet
and they have separated a little bit of
this one doesn't want to share at all
these ones all to itself to see
just exploited right around the Dinkley
Breitling incredible we've came here
expecting it maybe to see some shooter
and boy oh boy have we gotten a whole
lot more than just that had a whole
feeding a frenzy gee that started off
keeping those jackals at Weber once they
got in and alerted the hyena well it was
everyone's game after that as I said the
cheetah a long gone now I haven't can't
see them anywhere around and so it's
just down to the Jackals and the hyenas
Oscar's saying it sounds like it's kids
jury dinner yes well I grew up in a
family with four boys and I can
definitely agree with that the dinner
table can get quite a crazy when it
comes to kids and big families
looks like everyone is Meowth scratching
around for some remains the carcass it
seems like it's been barely pulled apart
near
yes I as I said being in a family of
four boys I know that's like to defend
that your food whilst also trying to eat
it at the same time yeah they're all
sniffing around for some remains piece
of carrion to carry on harm unintended
marci wants to know whether these
jackals are related to the dogs because
they say on the same well yes so they
are part of the Cana forms order which
is all of the dog like ones and then
there is the Fila forms which are your
cat like animals the Carnivora no it's a
sub water sorry sorry sub waters the
true supporters and carnivore is the
class Mammalia while we're going off the
taxonomic tree there okay so everything
has gone behind the car coming around
[Music]
Wow just when I thought it was starting
to die down and another dispute over
peace there
and it's still the action continues Wow
a is really really interesting just to
see the dynamics around the carcass
you know this has turned out to be
sorry I understand fixing up the some of
these cables here so I can get something
comes but it does seem like the action
that has all died down now thank you
always so much for joining us if this
wasn't enough for you we've always got
more Safari live to live drives a day so
make sure they search it Safari live on
YouTube and I hope to see you all soon
welcome aback everyone all of our
regular viewers what overjoyed at how
these a day has panned out I think it
must have been a st. Patrick's Day
blessing for sure my Irish heritage
really coming in handy today it seems
like they are still looking around a
little bit saying there's anything a
left well now that everything has died
down here I'm sure we can all start to
unwind with a bit more of a peaceful
shining mashaallah has some alleys yes
definitely geez Pat heart must be
beating so so fast that was so exciting
but yes this is a much more peaceful
more relaxed sighting elephants have
been so so good now look fool you'll
notice we iron infrared like I'm sure
some of the other guys have explained
explained so that we have no artificial
lights shining on to them so they
completely in their natural there we go
wasn't as interesting hmm so mum broke
that branch pulled it down almost for
the baby
so cool can you imagine being in the
darkness like this and you can hear the
shuffling and breaking of branches and
class
I can imagine be quite scary especially
here this big thing coming coming up
behind you even it's really dark now as
it is and when we came up towards them I
saw them in front of me but the head
take of my spotlight and check behind
and the sides as well because you will
never know if they're lurking just
behind the bushes you also had some
whooping hey you know it's calling not
too far from I would you know he's run
off just as soon as I decided to show
YouTube where are you I can smell you
I've even had one in my mouth
can you hear that and one is who is
whooping and the other one is responding
darkness of the bush reading is
something else
mm-hmm somebody's nose
[Music]
it's so good see if you're close by
stuffed elephants have moved up to the
side as well I'm quite happy this is
after Patrick's IT this is a very cold
relaxed kind of sighting I do I love it
elephants have moved off hyenas are
coming alive in the night time it really
is nice isn't it it's like a story time
of the African bush beautiful and I was
just saying to say it is a stunning
stunning evening this evening oh you
still in front of us let's move a little
bit forward to get a better view of you
something's nanded on me probably more
stinkbug
oh oh there's a tiny tiny tiny one look
how they're standing together almost
like a puzzle
so cute you see that little truck dang
you know and can you see that they're
quite stole apart from obviously baby in
trunk which doesn't seem to care too
much for listening out to the herd in
this but often when they stand like that
and they stand still
they're listening they listen to the
sounds that we can't hear well they're
listening to infrasonic sounds
beautiful
hey guys going for a nighttime stroll oh
I like that
how can you see that Thanks pick it up
just a little bit they're listening
they're concentrating they're unsure
what they were to do this there you go
guys absolutely stunning we've had such
an amazing Drive absolutely amazing
drive elephants one of those cheetah
jackal hyena
and of course ting gana always always a
pleasure
well you know it's that time thank you
so much for your questions and comments
and remember to join us again for the
sunrise Safari tomorrow morning thank
you and bye bye
[Music]